Hello friends [music] and welcome to
your program 3ABN today Bible Q&A.
I am greeting you from Southern
Illinois. My name is Idalia Dinzey and I
am so blessed and privileged to spend
this following hour with each one of
you. I know you're anticipating this
program so right up from the bat I want
you to get a pen, get something to write
on so you can take notes about the
references that we will be sharing
during this hour. Your program
Bible Q&A is
where you send your questions, your
comments, and praises
about the word of God. So we want you to
know that this program is for you and
we've been thinking about you and
praying for you as well as our
panelists. And it consists of our 3ABN
family and I am so honored to present to
you
Mr. John Dinzey.
Honey, welcome to the program. Thank
you. It's a blessing to be here and it's
a blessing to share this hour with you
and Pastor Johnson. Yes, and this is a
sight we see at our home across from the
table chitchatting about different
aspects of the Bible and life in
general. And we're privileged also to
share this hour with Pastor Ryan
Johnson. Welcome Pastor Johnson.
>> Thank you so much for having me sister
Dinzey. Thank you Dinzey family for
letting me sit at the table with you
here at home to discuss some stuff. I
really like how you said also send in
your praises. Yeah, I love that. Take an
opportunity to praise the Lord.
>> Amen. Yes, because when we praise the
Lord we are what? Encouraged. So what do
you say?
>> that. Be encouraged. Amen.
>> [laughter]
>> So during this hour we definitely are
going to be encouraged because
the Lord is with us and we've asked him
to
bless our time together but we want to
take a moment and pray with you right
now. You know sometimes when we want to
dive into the word and we want to
contemplate a message
Satan throws so many things at us to
distract us. So we don't want
distractions right now. We want you your
heart to be open to the spirit and your
ears to be anointed so you can hear what
the Lord has to say. So I'm going to ask
um
Pastor Dinzey, would you please have a
prayer for us? Sure. Let's go to the
Lord in prayer.
Our marvelous and wonderful heavenly
Father, we thank you so much Lord that
you have given us the privilege to share
from the Holy Scriptures. Amen. [music]
We humbly come before you and ask for
the blessing of your Holy Spirit. We
pray that you will speak through us and
that you [music] will speak to your
children as well wherever they may be.
And we pray that this will be of
encouragement to them. We pray Lord that
the Holy Scriptures will come alive and
that we will have a growing desire to
study the Scriptures with you Lord. We
ask you for a blessing upon [music] all
in the holy and blessed name of Jesus.
Amen. Amen.
Amen. Well, I'd like to share with you
that you know we as parents sometimes we
think our children don't have any big to
do questions but every question greater
small is important because that helps us
in the relationship with the Lord and
understanding his word. So we are
representing those families at home and
so we want to encourage you to send in
your questions and I'm going to share
the contact information right off the
bat because I know you what you're
saying. Oh, I wanted to send in a
question and I forgot. Well, you're
going to do it now. It is to the email
is bibleqa@3abn.tv.
bibleqa@3abn.tv.
And you can send a text at 618-228-3975.
618-228-3975.
And of course you Instagrammers have a
chance to send messages to at
3abn_official.
So at 3abn_official.
All right. Now we're going to get down
to business. So [snorts] we're going to
start with Pastor Ryan Johnson. Okay? So
we have email here that we received and
this is a question that many people have
but
perhaps
haven't dug into what it's really like
or what it's all about. So the first
question is how did sin originate in
heaven? Ah.
Well, that's a good question because
actually just by asking that question
you are presenting a bit of a conundrum.
But before we go to the conundrum, let's
just establish that heaven, the heavens,
the earth was created by God. God is
perfect. All of his works it says in
Genesis are good. So in the beginning
even before man and woman were formed of
the dust of the ground, God created a
perfect universe in harmony with him
reflecting his character. It was
perfect. And so the question that you
are asking, such a good question, is how
can something imperfect like sin
come out of something that God had
created perfect. You know, they call
that the mystery of iniquity and when we
study this we actually find a little
cautionary tale for us. But let's look
at what the Bible says. The Bible is
very clear.
Let's start in the book of Ezekiel. This
is a powerful prophetic book and I'm
going to begin in Ezekiel chapter 28 and
verse 12. Now stay with me. We're going
to dig down in here. Here's what it
says, "Son of man,
>> [clears throat]
>> take up a lamentation upon the king of
Tyrus and say unto him, Thus saith the
Lord God, Thou sealest up the sum full
of wisdom and perfect in beauty. Now
here is a message to the king of Tyre."
I think that was absolutely clear. But
these prophetic books are able to do
something really cool. They call it dual
fulfillment and also typology. You have
a type and then you have the antitype.
The Bible likes to use things that
actually happened there in their in
their relevant present or around the
present in order to prophesy about
things that shall happen or talk about
things that did happen. So here in the
28th chapter of Ezekiel starts off
talking about the king of Tyrus or Tyre
and then in verse 13 the conversation
changes. It says, "Thou hast been in
Eden." Oh, we're no longer talking about
just the king of Tyre.
"The garden of God and every precious
stone was thy covering, the sardis,
topaz, and the diamond, the beryl, the
onyx, the jasper, the sapphire." Oh,
that's beautiful. "The emerald and the
carbuncle and the gold, the workmanship
of thy tabrets and of thy pipes, a
singer was prepared in thee in the day
that thou was created." Clearly
something bigger
than just the king of Tyre is being
talked about here. And then verse 14,
"Thou art the anointed cherub that
covereth."
Cherub is an angel. Anointed references
the Holy Spirit. Oh, look at this. "And
I have set thee so. Thou was upon the
holy mountain of God." That phrase shows
the position of this creature. "Thou
hast walked up and down in the midst of
the stones of fire." That is symbolic of
the power of God. And then it says, "You
were perfect in your ways from the day
you were created until iniquity
was found in thee."
And then in verse 17, "Your heart was
lifted up." Why? Why was his heart
lifted up? Because of your beauty. Here
the origin of sin is being addressed.
But let's look at it in another place.
Turn with me to Isaiah chapter 14 and
I'm going to start reading in verse Oh,
let's go 11. It says, "Thy pomp is
brought down to the grave and the noise
of thy viols, the worm is spread under
thee and the worms cover thee." If you
read there you will see that the king of
Babylon is being addressed. But yet
again that dual fulfillment kicks in and
the prophet begins to talk about
something that has happened in ages
past. Verse 12, "How art thou fallen
from heaven, O Lucifer?"
Oh, you see that? "Son of the morning,
how art thou cut down to the ground
which did weaken the nations?"
Lucifer
is the originator of sin. Why? Why
Lucifer? Verse 13, "Because you have
said in your heart, I will ascend into
heaven. I will exalt my throne above the
stars of God." Mercy. "I will sit also
upon the mount of the congregation in
the sides of the north." And you can
look there prophetically north also
often means judgment. And then it goes
on to say that Lucifer declared, "I will
ascend above above the heights of the
clouds. I will be like the most high."
Satan wanted to be
greater than God.
That's blasphemy right there.
Now here's what we have. Ezekiel denotes
the pride that's going on but here we
see that it is bigger. Satan didn't just
have pride and narcissism, he wanted to
be God. And this is important because
often when we're talking about Satan
beginning his sin, we just say, "Well,
Sister Dinsy, Satan said he was pretty."
And Satan, we understand from Ezekiel,
was pretty, but we can see in Revelation
that he took a third of the angels with
him. He had a compelling argument. He
had to have something more strong than,
"Hey, I'm pretty. Let's try it. Pastor
Dinsy, I'm pretty. Follow me." It's not
working. [laughter]
First of all, I ain't pretty.
There must be something Satan had an
ideology.
A powerful argument here, and he sinned.
He fell. He had a campaign against God.
He had
politics against God. Well, can I say
that? Wow.
>> Oh, we went there, did we not? You sure
did.
>> This is the origin of sin, and
everything rolls off of that in Satan's
ongoing campaign against God in his
efforts to be greater than God, and
there's a term we give this. We call it
the great controversy.
God versus Satan.
And here we are
in the midst of it. Now, the Bible says
all have sinned and come short of God's
glory.
Satan influences, but he doesn't make us
sin. That's right. We are responsible
for what we have and what we do, but
Satan is the originator. Now, as we come
to the end here, the question was,
"How?" Mhm.
Because we just saw where and who.
And I was looking at this, Pastor Dinsy,
and I found something interesting.
First, let's appreciate the power of
choice. If Satan didn't have the power
of choice, then he could not have chosen
at all to sin.
God gave us something dangerous, I heard
a guy say today, when he gave us the
power of choice. I have these glasses,
and I'm going to put them down. Those
glasses cannot disobey me. Glasses,
right? Mhm. I do not want you to go out
and rob a bank. Mhm. But look at this.
Glasses,
sit there.
Are the glasses obeying me?
Without the power of choice, yes, we
cannot choose to sin, but can we also
really choose to obey?
God wanted us to be able to choose to
obey him, so we gave the power of choice
to his creatures, including Satan,
knowing that the risk of sin was there.
That's how loving God is, but here is
how. Here is how. Satan's name, Lucifer.
He might know what that means. Lucifer
means light-bearer, the bearer of light.
Now, in the Hebrew, his name is Halal,
which means shining one. Satan had
light. Now, let me ask you this. Where
did the light come from?
Remember when Moses came down off the
mountain and his face was shining? Where
did the light come from? Remember when
you sang that song in church and
somebody said, "Man, you really sound
good." Where did the light come from?
Satan forgot that God is the source of
light and felt like he was shining on
his own.
That
is how
sin began, and the cautionary tale is
that if we do not continue to give God
praise,
we may fall victim to the very same sin
of pride.
Okay, Sister Dinsy, I'm finally done.
Amen.
Well, I'm just here saying amen.
Hallelujah. Keep on preaching. So, we
are in church right now.
Uh thank you, Pastor Ryan, for your love
and passion for the Lord and for souls.
And thank you, whoever sent in that
email. Now, we're going to move on to
the next question, John Dinsy. Can you
please explain 2 Samuel 5:6-8?
Kathleen from Connecticut would like to
know.
Thank you, Kathleen. And as we look here
at 2 Samuel chapter 5:6-8,
we have to read it for the benefit of
those who do not have it memorized. I do
not. So, I let's begin. 2 Samuel chapter
5:6-8.
And the king and his men went to
Jerusalem against the Jebusites, the
inhabitants of the land, who spoke to
David, saying, "You shall not come in
here, but the blind and the lame will
repel you." Thinking, "David cannot come
in here." Nevertheless, David took the
stronghold of Zion, that is, the city of
David. Now, David said on that day,
"Whoever climbs up by the way of the
water shaft and defeats the Jebusites,
the lame and the blind, who are hated by
David, so he shall be chief and captain.
Therefore, they say, 'The blind and the
lame shall not come into the house.'"
So, the way this is This is
I read to you from the New King James
Version. In the
King James Version, it has it a little
different, and that's why I say to you,
when you are reading the scriptures,
when you are reading something that has
been translated, please understand that
there are difficulties in translating
from one language to another.
And the translators do their best to
bring you the most accurate translation.
Because when you go to 2 Kings,
uh chapter 2 Samuel
>> 2 Samuel. Thank you very much. Yes, I
thought so.
>> [laughter]
>> I almost went to the wrong place.
Uh so, let's go ahead and see what it
says. Uh
notice what it says in verse 6 in the
King James Version. And the king and his
men went to Jerusalem unto the
Jebusites, the inhabitants of the land,
which spake unto David, saying, "Except
thou take away the blind and the lame,
thou shall not come in hither."
Thinking, "David cannot come in hither."
In other words, uh when we look at this
verse and it says in the New King James,
"The lame and the blind will repel you."
What is going on here is that they were
so proud of their ability. They thought
they were so strong, so powerful, that
they're saying to David, "Hey,
we're so big and so tough that even the
lame and the blind are going to defeat
you. You cannot come in here."
>> [laughter]
>> But also in verse um
in verse 8, it seems to say that David
hated the lame and the blind.
So, when you think about David and you
understand that he loved the Lord with
all his heart, and he loved his neighbor
as himself, I'm quoting to you. I think
I'll read it from Matthew 22,
uh verses 37 to 39. This is what the
Lord is asking all of us.
Jesus said to him, "You shall love the
Lord your God with all your heart, with
all your soul, and with all your mind.
This is the first and great commandment.
And the second is like it, you shall
love your neighbor as yourself."
So, in essence, to say that David hated
the lame and the blind, that is making a
general statement. Whoever they are,
whether they be enemies or whether they
be
part of our family, David would hate the
lame and the blind, and that is not
true.
David loved his neighbor as himself.
He had potentially lame and blind among
the Israelites, among his people. So, he
This cannot be an accurate statement to
say that David hated the lame and the
blind.
It's interesting. Uh this is why I bring
to you another translation. This is from
the Jewish people that they wrote the
Tanakh. This is the 1985 version. They
translated the
what we call the Old Testament into
English. And I'll read it to you from
there to see if that helps. 2 Samuel
chapter 5:6-8.
The king and his men set out for
Jerusalem against the Jebusites, who
inhabited the region. David was told,
"You will never get in here. Even the
blind and the lame will turn you back."
They meant David will never enter here.
But David captured the stronghold. It is
now the city of David. On that occasion,
David said, "Those who attack the
Jebusites shall reach the water channel
and strike it down, the lame and the
blind, who are hateful to David." This
is why they say no one
who is blind or lame may enter into the
house. What it's saying is that the lame
and the blind hated David, not that
David hated them.
So, this is a quite different
understanding of what some people may
read as they just read it out loud
without really thinking and putting line
upon line and
precept upon precept, scripture upon
scripture. So, David did not hate the
lame and the blind because
he even had a family member that was a
lame individual, and he showed him
mercy.
I'll stop right there.
Uh we should have mercy for each other.
Show mercy. All right. Well, we thank
Kathleen from Connecticut who had sent
that text, and we're going to move on to
the next question, and this time it's
going to be addressed to uh Pastor Ryan
Johnson, and we want to thank Adolfo
from Wisconsin for sending in your text.
Now, Pastor Ryan,
if I die owing someone money,
will I be held responsible at judgment?
Oh.
Well, that's a powerful question, isn't
it?
>> Yes, it is. Well, friends, first of all,
hope you're doing okay. What was his
name you said? Adolfo. Adolfo. Adolfo. I
hope you're doing okay. Praise the Lord.
You know, we get questions like this, uh
similar questions to this, like um if
someone dies before I have a chance to
forgive them, um you know, will the Lord
hold me accountable? So, friends, let's
just set this up. So, let's suppose that
I borrowed some money from Sister Dinsy.
That's not a joke. Can I have $5, Sister
Dinsy?
>> [laughter]
>> Sorry, I have three. You can borrow
three.
So, she gives me her $3, you know, and
you know, Lord forbid, something falls
down and clunks me on the head, you
know, before I have a chance to give her
$3 back.
Am I held responsible? Will that keep me
out of glory? Well, first of all, the
idea that we should be good stewards is
not made up. Let's go ahead and see what
the Bible says about it. We're going to
start in Psalms 37, the 37th Psalm, and
I'm going to read verse I'm going to
start in verse 20. It says, "But the
wicked shall perish, and the enemies of
the Lord shall be as the fat of lambs.
They shall consume."
"Into smoke shall they consume away."
Well, that doesn't sound good.
Let's find out who the wicked are cuz we
don't want to be in that group, do we?
That's right.
>> Verse 21, "The wicked borroweth" Uh-oh.
"and payeth not again." Oh, have mercy.
>> [laughter]
>> But then it goes on to say, "But the
righteous
showeth mercy
and giveth." So, it seems as though
wickedness is clearly defined there.
But then so is righteousness. We kind of
fall into a little baby conundrum here
because think of it this way. Think of
it this way.
If everyone was being as righteous as
possible
and I borrowed money from Sister Dinsy
and she being righteous showed mercy
that absolves my debt. Nobody would owe
anybody anything.
>> Amen.
Is that biblical?
It seems as though the Bible is saying
something else here. This particular
text is not necessarily about paid
versus unpaid. Let's look at it from
another perspective. So, now we're going
to go to Romans chapter 13 and I'm going
to read verse 8. Now, this is a text
that I hear quoted very often
and it gives some good counsel. It says,
"Owe no man."
Well, since I was borrowing from Sister
Dinsy, "Owe no woman." Come on now.
That's right. Anything
"but to love one another." The love is
something that is never fully repaid.
You always give it. You always give it.
>> Yes. But it says, "Owe no man, no woman
anything for he that loveth another hath
fulfilled the law."
Okay.
Let's go on to verse 9. "For this" and
then the law is listed. "Thou shalt not
commit adultery. Thou shalt not kill.
Thou shalt not steal. Thou shalt not
bear false witness. Thou shalt not
covet." You notice they didn't start in
Paul does not start with "Have no other
gods before me." That's right.
>> These are all of the latter
commandments. And maybe you've heard
Jesus said there really only two
commandments. "Love the Lord thy God and
thy neighbor as thyself."
So, it's interesting that the
commandments that are cited here are the
commandments where we are to love our
neighbor as ourselves. Oh, we're
circling it now. Let's see what goes on.
It says, "Thou shalt not covet and if
there be any other commandment, it is
briefly comprehended in this saying."
Here's the saying, "Namely, thou shalt
love thy neighbor as thyself."
So, what is happening here?
These are texts
not necessarily just about owing and not
owing, getting paid and not being paid.
These are texts about having the mindset
or the heartset
of neighborly love.
The wicked
discussed in Psalms are wicked because
they don't have the heart to even want
to be good stewards with the $3 that
Sister Dinsy has given them. That is not
a love thy neighbor as thyself heart.
And the righteous are righteous because
they do not judge or hold over the head
those who owe $3.
This is a matter of the heart. But the
question is, I hear you, preacher.
But if I owe money
and I die before I get a chance to give
it back what does God say? Well, think
that's fair.
Now, I'd like to turn to 1 Samuel. We're
going to 1 Samuel chapter 16 and we're
going to read verse 7. And then we're
going to look at a case study.
Here's what God says to you, my brother.
It says, "But the Lord said unto Samuel,
'Look not on his countenance nor on the
height of his stature because I have
refused him, for the Lord seeth not as
man seeth.
Man looketh on the outward appearance,
but the Lord looks at the heart.'"
The Lord looks at your heart.
That is what is being determined when
the Lord examines us. What is and where
is your heart?
Look at your character.
Peradventure something happened before
you get a chance to pay it back. If you
were a good steward to the best of your
ability
you loved your neighbor as yourself,
praise God, you're going to be in the
kingdom.
Now, there's actually a case study of
this. We're going to go to Luke chapter
23. I'm going to start in verse 39.
Going to Luke 23:39. Give me a second to
find it here.
That last reference was 1 Samuel 20. Uh
yes, ma'am. 1 Samuel 16. Okay.
>> Verse 7. Yes, ma'am.
>> 16:7. Thank you.
>> And then Luke chapter What did I say?
23?
>> Luke 23:34.
39. All right.
>> Yes, that's it. The pages sticking
together here and here is a story you
are familiar with. This is a case study.
This is what puts it to bed.
It says, "And one of the malefactors
which were hanged railed on him saying,
'If thou be Christ, save thyself and
us.'" And immediately we zero in to this
part of the gospel narrative. We know
this is Christ on the cross. And on his
right and on his left there were two
completely guilty and sinful men
getting what they deserved.
"But the other answered rebuking him
saying, 'Dost thou not fear God seeing
thou art in the same condition, same
condemnation?'" Verse 42. "And he said
unto Jesus." He said unto Jesus,
"Lord, if you reach in my back pocket,
you will see 20 bucks that I owe to my
brother."
"Make sure he gets it when I" That is
not what he says. He says, "Lord,
remember me when you come in your
kingdom. Remember me, Lord." He gave
what he had. He did what he could and
Jesus says in verse 43, "Verily I say
unto you today, you will be with me in
paradise." Did the thief owe? Yes, he
owed. He owed big time and he was pinned
to the cross before he had an
opportunity to pay, but his heart was
right and he's [clears throat] going to
be in the kingdom.
That's what puts it to bed. Now, before
we finish this
we kind of have focused on money here.
But as we are being good stewards and
loving our neighbor, there are some
things that we owe that we need to tend
to. Do you owe somebody an apology?
Yes. Do you owe somebody love?
Huh?
Listen to me, husbands. Have you been
giving love to somebody else that
belongs to your wife?
Let us be good stewards with the
blessings the Lord has given us. And if
your heart's in the right place by His
grace
>> [laughter]
>> we'll be in the kingdom.
Amen. Thank you, Pastor Johnson. Thank
you. And thank you, Adolfo from
Wisconsin for texting us the question.
We move on now. We're going to go to
state of Ari- Arizona and Rhonda sent in
a text and this is what it says. And
John Dinsy, be ready. This is for you,
okay? Okay.
>> Ephesians 4:30, New King James Version
states, "Do not grieve the Holy Spirit
of God by whom you were sealed for the
day of redemption." What does it mean to
grieve the Holy Spirit? Does it mean to
have anger with the spirit? What do you
have to tell Rhonda and many others that
are listening in? Thank you, Rhonda. And
this is an interesting question and here
we see
an interesting statement. And I like to
read it again, you know, it says, "And
do not grieve the Holy Spirit of God by
whom you were sealed for the day of
redemption."
Uh this helps us to understand that
it's not true what some people say that
the Holy Spirit is a force or a wind
because you cannot grieve
wind or a force.
So, we're talking here about a person of
the Godhead of the deity. So, do not
grieve. Does it mean
something about anger? No, because the
word grieve is a Greek word lupeo which
means to cause pain or distress or to
grieve.
So, it is not talking about anger. But
can you bring sorrow to the Holy Spirit?
Remember that Jesus said that he's going
to send another comforter
the Holy Ghost
which will be in you.
And so
in essence we're seeing here that
we're not to grieve the comforter, the
one that has that Jesus says, "I will be
with you always." Through the Holy
Spirit Jesus is with us. And so to to
grieve
the Holy Spirit in essence by our words
and our actions
is you're trying is like
it's like somebody's trying to feed you
and you're
slapping their hand, no, and pushing
them away when they're trying to do you
good. Mhm. To help you. And so, this is
a very powerful scripture to consider,
meditate upon because
the Bible helps us to understand that
God means to do us good. He wants to
help us. He wants to bless us. And so,
here, do not grieve
uh the Holy Spirit and in essence it
said, "Do Do not act towards the Holy
Spirit in a manner which will produce
pain in the bosom of a friend, somebody
that's trying to help you."
>> Mhm. And so, [clears throat] this This
is by the way we act, by the way we
behave. In other words, the Holy Spirit
is also leading us towards doing good
things and saying good things. Mhm. So,
if we're
in essence pushing away Rejecting.
>> rejecting Okay. the Holy Spirit by our
words and our actions, we need to be
careful with that and that is an
invitation by Paul to tell them to
remain faithful to the Lord because when
you look at Ephesians chapter 4 verse
30, um he he is bringing out, uh for
example,
it says in verse 20, "But you have not
so learned Christ. If indeed you have
heard and have been taught by him as the
truth as it is in Jesus that you put off
concerning your former conduct the old
man which grows corrupt according to the
deceitful lust and be renewed in the
spirit of your mind and that you put on
new man which was created according to
God in true righteousness and holiness."
And so, there are scriptures that it
continues saying, "Therefore, put away
lying. Let each one of you speak truth
with his neighbor for we are members of
one another. Be angry and do not sin.
Mhm. Do not let the sun go down on your
wrath nor give place to the devil. Let
him who stole steal no more, but rather
let him labor working with his hands
what is good that he may have something
to give to him who has need. Let no
corrupt word proceed out of your mouth,
but what is good for necessary
edification that it may impart grace to
the hearers." And that's when it says,
"And do not grieve the Holy Spirit." So,
you see, the Holy Spirit is leading us
to righteousness, leading us to holiness
and to
to act contrary to the Holy Spirit is
doing you harm. So, this is what this
bring being brought out here.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, I just want to remind
you all at home that you have an
opportunity to send in
your questions. Um we're going to share
you the email where you can send your
questions to the program so that way
you're
you're at peace because it's Bible
answers. All right, it's email
bibleqa@3abn.tv.
bibleqa@3abn.tv
and you can send a text at 618-228-3975.
618-228-3975.
And for you Instagrammers, of course, we
have @3abn_official,
@3abn_official.
And you, by the way, can share these
programs on your social media platforms
because these questions are real
questions that your friends and contacts
may have, but don't know about the
program yet. So, you are going to
connect them with us. All right, we're
moving on to the next question and we're
going to Pastor Johnson. I want to thank
Carol for taking her time of sending
that email and this is what it says.
Thanks, Carol. It says, "Why do some
programs, sermons, and studies focus so
much on the power of the devil? Mhm.
When the topic emphasizes his strength,
it can feel it frightening and I
sometimes turn away. I love 3ABN and its
programs, but I wish discussions about
evil could be presented in a way that
doesn't scare people. Pastor, what do
you got to say?
>> me with it, Carol.
>> the Bible say? Well, first of all,
Carol, I got to be honest with you. Um
as one of the pre-pastors here at 3ABN,
my my first reaction is, "No, we don't."
But But you know what? I remember one
time I was preaching somewhere and I got
up and I was saying, "Oh, the Lord has
been good to us, hasn't he? He uh woke
us up this morning meaning we didn't die
in our sleep. He brought us here safely
meaning we didn't get in a car accident.
We are not in the hospital as means we
are not sick." And then I realized, "Are
we
Are we basing all of our blessings just
on the evil that does not happen?
Who's defining blessing here? And then I
had to appreciate, Sister Carol, there
are blessing, first of all, that's
mercy. Praise the Lord he woke us up.
Praise the Lord he brought us here.
Praise the Lord that we have our health
and even if you're struggling with
health, you're breathing, praise the
name of the Lord. But there are
blessings that have nothing to do with
the devil, got nothing to do with it.
Here's one, the sun came over the
horizon this morning. Come on, friends.
The Lord did that. That feeling of
encouragement that you received, the
Lord did that. There are blessings that
take place in the farthest reaches and
corners of the universe.
The Lord is doing mighty things. And you
know what, Sister Carol, I feel better
just having said that. So, thank you for
the opportunity. Nevertheless,
you got a point.
What is happening Mhm. when we seem in
these last days to focus, well, let's
just look at the Bible and just see
where it is that we are and why it is
that we are so passionate about
spreading the gospel and the warning to
people all over the world? Well, it says
in Revelation chapter 18, and I'm going
to say this to try to make somebody mad,
the three angels message in Revelation
18, somebody's mad already. Listen what
it says in verse 4. It says, "I heard
another voice from heaven saying, 'Come
out of her, my people,
that ye be not partakers of her sins,
that ye receive not of her plagues, for
her sins have reached unto heaven and
God hath remembered her iniquities.' And
the reason I was saying make somebody
mad is I know there are theologians
going, 'Pastor, the three angels message
is found in the 14th chapter of
Revelation.' But you can hear the
phrasing here is very close to
Revelation 14:8 where it says, 'Babylon
is fallen
is fallen.'
And here it says in 18, "Come out of
her, my people." I want you to imagine
that you're in a room
>> [snorts]
>> and everybody [clears throat] is in
there eating and having a good time and
you look over in the corner and there's
fire.
The fire is burning
and it's spreading quickly.
And then then imagine the Lord says into
your ear, "You need to let these people
know that this building will not stand.
They need to come into the safety of the
outside." And then you jump up and you
have a warning. You say, "Everyone, the
building is fallen. The building is on
fire. The Lord has given a warning for
me to give to you. Let us go into the
ark and be saved." And what you are
seeing at 3ABN and in pulpits and stuff
is people having the passion of one that
has been given a specific message of
warning. Let the world know Amen. that
Jesus is coming soon. In fact, let's go
to Matthew chapter 24 and look at it
from there. The disciples say at the
very top of Matthew 24, he said they
said, "What shall be the sign of thy
coming?" Now, we are not going to read
the whole chapter, but I want you to
look what Jesus says in verse 4. Jesus
answered and said unto them, "Take heed
that no man deceive you." Okay, verse 5.
"For many shall come in my name saying,
'I am Christ and shall deceive many.'
Verse 11. 'And many false prophets shall
rise and deceive many.' Verse 24. 'For
there shall arise false Christs, false
prophets, and shall show great signs and
wonders in so much that if it were
possible, they shall deceive
the very elect."
Satan is out there prowling with
deception and the Lord has given us a
message, a warning, the three angels
message to preach to the world, "Come
out of confusion and false worship." To
preach to the world, "Give glory to
God." To preach to the world, "His
judgment is upon us." And so, what you
see happening, Sister Carol, is we're
just looking at the prophecy the Lord
has given us to prepare us and we're
just passionately letting the world know
that this is not a time to play around.
This is a time to get it right with God.
Wow.
But
I feel you, though.
I feel you. Do we have to focus on the
negative? Let's look at the same
prophecies. Turn this telescope around
and see it from a different perspective.
Let's go to John chapter 16 and verse
33. What does the Bible say? It says,
see if I can find it here, 16:33. Let's
start in verse 32. "Behold, the hour
cometh, yea, is now come that ye shall
be scattered." Here's the devil, the bad
part. "Every man to his own and shall
leave me alone and yet I am not alone
because the Father is with me." But then
he says in verse 33, "Listen, Carol,
listen. These things have I spoken unto
you that in me you might have peace."
Peace in the middle of the last days.
"In the world you going to have
tribulation, but be of good cheer. I
have overcome the world."
Feels good when we say it like that,
doesn't it? Well, let's look at another
one. Now, I'm going to Luke chapter 21
and I'm going to read verse 28. "When
these things begin to come to pass,
then look up, Carol. Lift up your head.
Your redemption draweth nigh."
So, you're right.
There is a way to look at prophecy from
a very final and extremely important
perspective, and it is, guess what? In
the end,
Christ wins. Amen. Christ wins. Be
encouraged, my sister. Christ wins. But,
forgive us.
We're just passionate about the warning
the Lord has given us.
Because there are some right now
in a burning room,
Mhm. in burning homes, Mhm. in burning
relationships,
Yes. in burning churches.
And we are to tell them,
"This is not a time to play around."
That's right.
This is a time Mhm. to get it right.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Praise God.
Oof. I wish this program was 2 hours
long. All right. I am puzzled. Jenny
from Washington sent a text. She says,
"I am puzzled by Mark 6:48, John Dinsy,
where Jesus walks on the water. It says
he would have passed by the disciples in
the boat. Is there a reason for this?
Why didn't Jesus just go directly to the
disciples in Mark 6:48?"
That's a wonderful question, and it's
interesting the way it's worded. You
know, there's a time when there's Jesus
is walking by,
and there was a blind Bartimaeus,
and Jesus kept on walking, but blind
Bartimaeus, he heard all the noise, and
he came to the conclusion,
"I think Jesus is here." And he began to
cry, "Jesus, thou son of David, have
mercy upon me." And he kept repeating
this. They said, "Shut up. Shut up.
Quiet. Quiet. You're going to disturb
the master."
But, he kept shouting.
And so, Jesus stopped Mhm. and said,
"Bring him here."
And Jesus, they brought him before him,
and Jesus said, "What do you want for me
to do for you?"
Now, Jesus knew that he was blind.
He could have said, "Oh, I see that
you're blind." And healed him. Right.
>> Jesus wanted him to express his faith.
And that's why he he asked the question.
And so, in this situation, there's a
reason why Jesus does things. It's not
that he's he's um
just continuing his walk ignorant of the
suffering that his disciples are in,
and fearful uh their feet their afraid
for their lives here. Uh let's go to
Mark chapter 6. Mhm. And beginning in
verse 45,
Okay. it says, "Immediately he made his
disciples get into the boat and go
before him to the other side to
Bethsaida, while he sent the multitude
away. And when he had sent them away, he
departed to the mountain to pray.
Now, when the evening was come,
the boat was in the middle of the sea,
and he was alone
on the land.
Then he saw them straining at rowing,
for the wind was against them.
Now, about the fourth watch of the
night, he came to them walking on the
sea and would have passed them by. This
is the part that is intriguing. What? It
looks like Jesus is just going to keep
on going and leave his disciples there
rowing and
potentially drowned with the boat.
Now, notice, "And when they saw him
walking on the sea, they supposed it was
a ghost." ghost
and cried out. Now, if Jesus started
heading straight for them, Ah. imagine
>> Yeah. "There's a ghost coming straight
for us. We're we're done. We're going to
die. We're going to die." It would have
been more shocking to them. I see. So,
this was for their benefit that Jesus
appeared to be passing by,
and they saw him. For they all saw him
and were troubled.
But, immediately
he talked with them and said to them,
"Now, if Jesus was not interested, he
would have kept on going. He would
ignore them." Mhm. But, notice what he
says. He's calming their fear. Mhm. "Be
of good cheer. It is I. Do not be
afraid." Do not be afraid. What happens
next?
Jesus says
uh Peter says, "Lord, if it is you,
let me come on the water." What? And
Jesus said, "Come." Yes.
>> So, Peter starts walking on the water,
and of course, you know what happens.
You know the story. He begins to sink.
Mhm. And so, we have to cut the story
short, but he begins to sink, and Jesus
he said something that we can all say
Mhm.
when we have we don't know what to say.
"Lord, Yeah. save me." Yes. Amen. And if
you're going through troubles and
difficulties, Mhm. you can call out to
the Lord. "Lord, save me." Yeah. Yes.
And the Bible says immediately, Yes.
immediately Jesus uh saved them, grabbed
them by the hand, and when they walked
onto the boat, what does the Bible say?
Everything became a calm, serenity,
peace. And so, when you have Jesus, we
need to have peace. He offers us his
peace. So, it is for their benefit, and
he wanted them to exercise faith that he
appeared to keep going. Now,
you you remember back in in the book of
Genesis, there were three individuals
walking. Abraham saw them.
And they appeared to keep going.
And he ran to them and said, "Please,
please,
stay with me.
Refresh yourselves. Have some food."
And so, the Lord sometimes does these
things to catch our attention. Now, he
purposely Jesus purposely walked close
enough to them that they saw him
because, you know, there's a storm,
they're afraid. But, it was all a
It notice that it says, we read before,
he saw them. Mhm. He saw them, and
that's why he went to them. So, the
purpose of Jesus going out walking on
the sea was to help his disciples not to
be blind. Amen. Amen. We're ready for
the next question. And Melissa, we want
to thank you for sending in your email,
and Pastor Ryan Johnson is going to
answer your question. This is what it
says. "I've been part of the church for
many years, and I noticed that the new
age or secular style music is being
included in some services. How can I
address this in a well-received way?
When I mention the Bible, people often
dismiss me and say I am being
judgmental. They argue that drums and
guitars are fine as long as there is
worship and the kids are enjoying
themselves. Are there scriptures that
define true worship music?" Oh, wow.
Well, thank you so much for your
question, and Mhm. we're going to get
into it. Well, let's just start at the
beginning. First, worship must be
God-centered and grounded in truth. Mhm.
>> John 4:23 and 24. I'm going to start in
24. "God is a spirit, and they that
worship him must worship him in spirit
and in truth." So, must be truth in
there. Worship must be spirit-led.
Hebrews 12:28 and 29. "Wherefore we
receiving a kingdom which cannot be
moved, let us have grace whereby we may
serve God acceptably
with reverence." There's a word, and
godly fear. For our God is a consuming
fire. I think about Habakkuk, where it
says, "The Lord is in his holy temple,
and all the earth keep silent." Now,
that doesn't mean nobody's saying
anything in the temple, but we're
talking about bringing reverence to the
Lord. So, it is appropriate to say that
reverence matters. It's biblical. So, in
the context of the question, we should
ask our fellow church family,
"Is this biblical?
Who are we exalting?
Is it God?
Yes, God. Is it?
That's the question."
Cuz however, and I say this very
carefully,
I have seen this issue being used to
divide congregations. I have. And Satan
is so crafty. On one end, we should
reverence the Lord, and then the other
people will bring up, "Yeah, but David
danced before the Lord." And while we're
going back and forth, the devil is just
laughing. So, let's just see some truth
here.
Don't be mad at me.
There is no scripture banning any
instrument, not even drums.
Find it and send it in, and we will say
we were wrong, but it is not there.
Please don't be mad. There is counsel
that is given to the church that tells
us how we should how we should worship.
And I'm a product of Pastor Ervin Dinsy,
also. So, I tend to be a little on the
conservative slide. But, we one time,
Pastor Dinsy, interviewed on the Today
program a group of people who were going
and they were freeing slaves, actual
slaves in India. People who had been
making bricks since they were born. And
for $1,500, they set a whole family
free. And when the family went to
church, you know what they did? They
praised the Lord with drums and
everything they had. And when I heard
that, I thought, "How pure that praise
must be." the heart Yes, ma'am, the
heart. So, we must be careful not to
judge. Let us not allow this issue to
distract us from the work. But,
simultaneously,
let us not allow worldly worship into
God's space.
So, we must be careful that we love our
neighbor. And we must be careful that
our love for our preferred worship style
does not exceed our love for one
another, cuz the devil would love to
divide us over tempo,
while people are yearning for the truth.
Wow. So, the question is, does it exalt
God? That's how I would put it, my
sister. I would ask them, "Is this
exalting God?" Okay. As far as I'm going
to go without getting too much trouble.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, I want to thank you, Pastor Ryan
Johnson. I want to thank you, too,
Pastor John Dinsy. I It's a pleasure for
me to have you at home and you studying
you love the Lord, and thank you for
being that inspiration to to your
family. And you guys are an inspiration
to all of us here, your 3ABN family, and
we have a purpose here, and you are part
of our purpose. We're here to serve you.
So, under God's guidance, we receive
your questions and God's guidance to
study and present to you Bible truths.
We're going to take a break and we will
be right back.
>> [music]
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday
[music] we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word [music] to shed
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand. To have your questions
[music] answered on a future program,
just email them to us at
bibleqa@3abn.tv.
[music]
That's bibleqa@3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
[music] 618-228-3975. That's
618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live, and then watch 3ABN Bible Q&A
for answers from [music] God's word.
Very well. We have a moment now to have
closing statements from our panelists.
So, Pastor Johnson?
Oh, thank you. You know, I was really,
really touched by two of the questions.
The one that said, you know, why do we
focus so much on the bad stuff, you
know? And then also the one where we're
talking about um the correct way to
worship and stuff. You know, there's a
God-fearing people asking passionate
questions, and I really appreciate a
chance for us to go into the word, see
what the Bible says, and also seek unity
as we as we sort these things out. So,
be encouraged, friends. Amen. Be
encouraged. And Jan Dinsay, you have
some encouraging words for us? Uh yes,
in this last question that I was uh
talking about the disciples, you know,
they're in the middle of the sea,
they're helpless. The situation is
helpless. And God sees them. And God
sees them. It it it says there, you
know,
he saw them straining and rowing. He's
concerned. He goes out there
to help them walking on the water, you
know? And when we are facing
difficulties like the disciples, we
focus on the rain, the storm, the
lightning, the thunder. Our boat is
getting full of water. And that's life's
situations, you know, the difficulties,
and we we're trying to do it ourselves.
We're trying to
uh survive this storm by ourselves.
But, call out to Jesus.
Allow him to come in.
Because when we do that,
we have protection, we have the peace of
the Lord, we have security and assurance
that like like it says in the Bible uh
in the Bible, it says, "And this light
affliction, which is but for a moment,
is working in us a far more eternal
weight of glory." Because the things
that are seen
are temporary, but the things that are
not seen are eternal. And I also want to
bring out Romans 8:28. All things work
together for good to them that love God.
So, whatever you're going through right
now, consider Jesus knows. Invite him
into your boat. Invite him into your
household, your life, and let him take
control. Because when Jesus got into the
boat, there was peace. You know, if I
may, I'd like to add something here.
They saw Jesus. Yes. He was present.
The struggle was real, the storm was
real, you know? And sometimes we focus
on the negative, and we forget that his
word and his promise is that I am with
you always. So, cry out to the Lord. He
is with you. God bless you, and we will
see you in the [music] other episode of
Bible Q&A.